for me the best example of a very very
large company converting from a real
reliability focus that was stifling
innovation slowing their growth is
Proctor and Gamble
one change they made is AG Lafley
declared that there are two moments of
truth the first moment of truth is when
you as a consumer either pick a proctor
product off the shelf or not and then
the second moment of truth is when you
take it home and use it if it's Olay you
put it on your skin and see whether it
has the effect that you hoped it would
so the first thing he said is we are too
much focused on only the second moment
of truth that's super important there's
no question that if you put the Olay on
your face and you don't light like its
effect you're not going to go and pick
it off the shelf the next time but if
you've never picked it off the shelf
because it's hard to find it doesn't
look good on the shelf the retailer
isn't supporting it enough then you'll
never get to the second moment of truth
notice is that an or we either have to
win at the first moment of truth or the
second moment of truth no it's an and we
have to win it both of these moments of
truth and the second thing about the
consumer was taking a much more holistic
view of the consumer the old-fashioned
Procter gamble would say okay women what
do they want they go ask the women well
I wanted to cover my pores and I wanted
to make my skin more subtle they would
be satisfied with that
what are your physical needs and if the
woman said and by the way I just want to
make I want to feel wanted and
attractive the Procter & Gamble Rd
people with oh you know don't talk about
that desirable I don't know how to do
desirable I know who I know how to to
make that more viscous so it covers your
pores better but is it don't talk to me
about that and they really started
understanding that there are a whole set
of emotional psychological needs how
does this make me feel what kind of a
person does this make me feel I am so
that they were appealing more
holistically to the consumer and that's
why circa 2000 you could buy oil of olay
little pink bottle you remember that 399
now you don't buy oil of olay oil went
away you buy Olay pro-x for $50 a bottle
AG Lafley just sort of says anybody can
do or if you want to be the best company
in your industry you've got to do and
with that attitude anybody can do or if
you want to be the best in your industry
you've got to do and if you got that I
think actually everything is doable